digamos que estamos tratando de entender
la relación entre la estatura de las
personas y su peso lo que hacemos es
medir la estatura y el peso de 10
personas y gráfica mos los datos de
estatura y peso en este diagrama de
dispersión en donde cada punto
representa una de las diez personas que
medimos por ejemplo este punto
representa una persona que tiene una
estatura de 60 pulgadas escribimos 60
coma y su peso que tenemos en el eje es
de 125 libras así que ponemos 125 y
cerramos el paréntesis cuando observamos
este diagrama de dispersión nuestra
vista reconoce de manera natural una
cierta tendencia parece que en general
cuando una persona es más alta también
tiende a pesar más pero hago énfasis en
lo de en general pues definitivamente
hay circunstancias en las que personas
más altas pueden pesar menos aquí la
pregunta que nos hacemos es podemos
tratar de ajustar una recta a estos
datos a la idea de tratar de ajustar una
recta
a cerca que se pueda a la mayor cantidad
de datos posibles se le conoce como
regresión lineal la técnica más común
para hacer esto es tratar de ajustar la
recta que minimice el cuadrado de la
distancia a cada punto de la gráfica y
hablaremos de esto en futuros vídeos
pero por ahora vamos a tratar de
comprender esta idea de forma intuitiva
ahora si pusiéramos una línea cualquiera
a ojo como por ejemplo esta no
pensaríamos que es un buen ajuste pues
nos damos cuenta de que no coincide
mucho con estos puntos porque la mayor
parte de los datos está por arriba de la
recta de forma similar si dibujamos una
recta como ésta nos damos cuenta de que
tampoco se ajusta muy bien que digamos a
los datos pues vemos que la mayor parte
de los puntos están por debajo de la
recta pero si dibujamos una recta como
ésta entonces la cosa cambia ya que
parece que se acerca lo más que se puede
a la mayor cantidad de puntos posibles y
parece que está describiendo esta
tendencia general así que esta es la
recta de regresión real vamos a escribir
su ecuación como jenson
pero el sombrero quiere decir que
tratamos de estimar una y para una x
dada no siempre va a ser layer real para
una x dada porque como podemos ver no
todos los puntos de la gráfica se
encuentran sobre la recta de regresión
así que ye sombrero es igual a la
ordenada al origen que para esta recta
de regresión en particular es menos 140
más la pendiente que es 14 entre 3 por
equis podemos ver que para la mayoría de
estos puntos dado el valor x de estos
puntos la estimación que nos da la recta
de regresión es diferente al valor real
de la coordenada ye la diferencia entre
el valor real de la coordenada ye y el
valor estimado por la recta de regresión
se conoce como residuo por ejemplo el
residuo de este punto para una x dada es
igual al valor real de la coordenada y
menos el valor estimado de dicha
coordenada ya que nos la da la recta de
regresión para la misma x otra forma de
pensar en esto es que para el valor x en
particular en este caso 60
el residuo para este punto es el valor
real menos el valor 10 sombrero que nos
da la recta de regresión para este valor
de x pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcular el valor del residuo para este
punto visualmente podemos decir que es
este segmento de acá
para calcular el residuo tomamos el
valor real de la ye para esta x en
particular que es 125 y le vamos a
restar el valor estimado podemos ver
esta ecuación y ver cuánto tendría que
valer 10 sombrero cuando x es igual a 60
va a ser igual a menos 140 más 14 entre
3 por 60 veamos
60 entre 3 es 20 20 por 14 es 280 y si
restamos estos 140 nos da como resultado
140 así que el residuo de este punto es
125 menos 140 que es igual a menos 15 y
efectivamente los residuos pueden ser
negativos si el residuo es negativo
significa que para este valor dado de x
el valor real de g
del punto se encuentra por debajo del
valor estimado si calculamos los
residuos de estos puntos de acá arriba
veremos que son positivos ya que el
valor real de y para sus
correspondientes valores de x están por
arriba del a
de regresión más adelante veremos en el
curso de estadística que la forma en que
calculamos esta recta de regresión es al
minimizar el cuadrado de estos residuos
con esto terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo